[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
وهذه العربيه
قال من المفاوضات والتعهدات الى مرحله
يحظى فيها التنفيذ بالاولويه
مؤتمر كوبا 27 يفتتح اعماله على اختراق
بادراج بند التعويضات
وتحذير من ان الوقت ينفذ امام العالم
الاجهاد يدفع دعمي اوكرانيا لفتح قوه
تفاوض في جدار الحرب وخرسون قد تهدم
الجدار بالكامل
وجه ايطالي حاضر في حمله الجمهوريين
لاستعاده الكونجرس وبنسلفانيا كما هي
كرتون رابح
اول فوضوي تويتر تعاني من معامله ماسك لها
كشريكه ناشئه وماسودون المستفيده الاول
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مع البدايه من ملفي المناخ وقمه
شرم الشيخ حيث حذر الامين العام للامم
المتحده
الغازات المسببه للاحتباس الحراري اخذه في
التزايد بشكل غير مسبوق مشددا على ان قمه
لتجنب الكوارث المناخيه
لاعاده بناء الثقه واعاده تاسيس الطموح
اللازم لتجنب كوكبنا كارثه مناخيه في
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه تلقينا تقريرا
تلو الاخر يوضح الصوره القادمه لا تزال
الانبعاثات تتزايد عند مستويات قياسيه
بدلا من الانخفاض بنسبه 45% بحلول عام
2030 انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري في
طريقه الان للارتفاع بنسبه 10% وفي الوقت
نفسه فان درجات الحراره في طريقها
للارتفاع بما يصل الى دراجتين فاصله
ثمانيه مع اتباع السياسات الحاليه بحلول
نهايه القرن سيبقى المناخ الى الابد في
ارتفاع كارثي بدرجات الحراره
اذا العالم يعمل على اعطاء دفعه جديده
لمكافحه تغير المناخ وتداعياته التي تتولى
في عالم منقسم وقلق من ازمات اخرى اليوم
انطلق مؤتمر الامم المتحده حول المناخ
السابع والعشرون بمدينه شرم الشيخ وقال
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي على
تويتر ان مصر بصفتها الدوله المضيفه تسعى
للانتقال من مرحله التعهدات الى مرحله
التنفيذي باجراءات ملموسه من جانبه شدد
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري على ان
بلاده لن تندخير جهدا لتحقيق اهداف
اتفاقيه باريس
ان الوقت قد حال للانتقال من المفاوضات
والتعهدات الى مرحله يحظى فيها التنفيذ
بالاولويه وفاه ذلك حتميه التعجيل بتنفيذ
ما ترادين عليه في الاتفاقيه الايطاليه
لتغير المناخ
وعززنا في اتفاق باريس وبرنامج العمل
الخاص به مع ضروره رفع مستوى الطموح لكل
الدول وفقا لقدراتها المتباينه
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده اليوم بان كل من السنوات
الثمن الاخيره ستكون اكثر حرارا من اي عام
سابق لعام 2015 المنظمه العالميه للارصاد
الجويه اشعارات ايضا الى تسارع وتيره
ارتفاع مستوى مياه البحار وذوبان الانهار
الجليديه اضافه لتزايد موجات الحر
والكوارث التي تتسببها في كلمته
الافتتاحيه سلطه رئيس لجنه الامم المتحده
لعلماء المناخ الضوء على الضروره الملحه
لخفض انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري
واكد ان العالم ابقى على الهدف الرامي
لارتفاع حراره الارض دون الدرجه ونصفه
وكان هذا العام شهد حتى الان سلسله من
الظواهر المناخيه المتطرفه التي فاقمها
التغير المناخي على سبيل المثال غمرت
فيضانات باكستان ثلث مساحه البلاد
قادها فيها ما لا يقل عن 1700 شخص اما في
شرق افريقيا فقد انحسر تساقط الامطار
لاربعه مواسم متتاليه ما فاق ما ازمه
الجفاف هناك بدورها شهدت الصين اطول موجه
حر تسجل حتى الان وثاني اكثر فصول الصيف
جفاف
[موسيقى]
النقطه الابراج اليوم كانت ملف التعويضات
والخسائر نتعرف معك يا طاهر عن هذا الملف
المهم جدا والذي شغل
العالمي الماضي في اجتماعات النظر رسميا
في قضيه الخسائر والتعويضات للدول اضعف
التي تعاني من تغير المناخ اليوم تم
الاتفاق اذا على هذه القضيه التي اثرت على
المحادثات لسنوات وادرجت على جدول الاعمال
قبل ساعات فقط من الافتتاح الرسمي
للاجتماع عباره الخسائر والاضرار تشير الى
تكاليف الخسائر التي تسببت فيها بالفعل
الظواهر المناخيه مع تداعياتها مثل ارتفاع
مستويات سطح البحر لكن تمويل الخسائر
والاضرار سيكون مختلفا اذن سيكون بمثابه
تعويض عن التكاليف التي لا تستطيع الدول
تجنبها او التكيف معها حتى الان
تتفق الدول بشان ما الذي يجب تصنيفه كسائر
او اضرار في الكوارث المناخيه فقد تشمل
البنيه التحتيه والممتلكات المتضرره اضافه
لاشياء لا تقدر بثمن مثل النظم البيئيه
الطبيعيه او الاصول الثقافيه والمقابر حتى
قبل ذلك وعدت دول الغنيه برفع مساعداتها
لدول الجنوب الى مئه مليار دولار سنويا
اعتبارا من 2020 لخفض الانبعاثات
والاستعداد لتداعيات التغير المناخي لكن
الدول لم تفي بوعودها تلك واكتفت العمل
الماضي بفتح حوار حول مساله التعويضات هو
ما اسفه عليه بالضبط وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري الذي افتتح هذه الدوره اليوم
عدم الالتزام بالوعود
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده خففت من مقاومتها لمشروع
انشاء الدول الغنيه لصندوق تعويضات
للبلدان الناميه ولكنها بالتوازي تواصل
مطالبه الصين بضروره الدفع ايضا باعتبارها
المصدر الاكبر للانبعثات الغازيه ومع
الجدل بشان التعويضات يبرز سؤالا من يدفع
ومن يحصل على الاموال الدول
يقولون ان الدول الغنيه التي تسببت بالجزء
الاكبر من تغير المناخ يجب ان تدفع طبيعي
وهو ما ترفضه الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي خشيه الدخول في دوامه من
الالتزامات الارقام مهوله في الواقع واذا
ما وافقت الدول على تدشين صندوق فانها
ستحتاج الى الافصاحه عن التفاصيل مثل ما
هي الدول المستحقه للتعويض او الكوارث
التي تؤهلها للحصول على تعويضات حتى الان
قدم عدد قليل على الحكومات التزامات تمويل
محدوده ورمزيه من اجل الخسائر والاضرار
وهي الدانمارك وسكتلندا بالاضافه الى
منطقه ولونيا البلجيكيه
يساعد بعض التمويل القائم من الامم
المتحده وبنك التنميه يساعد الدول على
مواجهه الخسائر والاضرار رغم انه غير مخصص
رسميا لهذا الهدف
[موسيقى]
واحلى هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان
السيد عمر شوشان المختص في سياسات المناخ
اهلا بك سيد عمر معنا الليله يعني يبدو ان
بعض بند تحديدا بند التعويضات سياخذ حيزا
كبيرا في مناقشات الايام القادمه من قمه
المناخ هو يتمحور حول نقطتين من المستحق
واي كوارث طبيعيه
انها كارثه وسيتم دفع المستحقات او
التعويضات
فسر لنا اكثر عنها ثاني النقطتين
بكل تاكيد بان الرئاسه المصريه يعني قمه
السابع والعشرين او النسخه السابعه
والعشرين من مؤتمر الاطراف التغير المناخي
تسلمت تريكه ثقيله من الرئاسه البريطانيه
التي كانت تتراس قمه المناخ الاخيره في
غلاسكو بكل تاكيد بان يعني ادراج الماده
القانونيه المتعلقه في الخسائر والضرر وهي
ماده رئيسيه من المواد في الاتفاقيه
الايطاليه لتغيير المناخي في اجنده قمه
شرم الشيخ هذا يعني يعتبر همم الى حد ما
انجاز ولكن الانجاز الاكبر وان المهمه
الرئيسيه ستكمل حين يعني يتبين كيفيه
تحديد اليات
والاجراءات التنفيذيه على الارض كيفيه
احتساب الخسائر
والضرر بكل تاكيد بانها يعني ماده حرجه
للغايه ويعني ستشهد الى حد ما عدم توافقات
خاصه بان يعني الدول الاقتصاديه الكبرى
تعاني ما تعانيه الان في ظل الازمه
الاوكراني الروسيه وايضا ازمه الطاقه وكما
ذكر يعني صندوق النقد الدولي بان العالم
مقبل على يعني حاله من التباطؤ الاقتصادي
خاصه للعام المقبل فلذلك اعتقد في ظل هذه
الظروف الاقتصاديه همم سيحاول جاهدا ال-
ال- يعني الدول المتقدمه والدول الصناعيه
همم ان همم تجد صيغه توافقيه الى حد
الموضوع صعب
كثيرا على انه سيتم التوصل الى اتفاق
حقيقي عملي لانه الارقام مهوله نتحدث عن
نحو عن قاعات ب 1,800 مليار بالالفين يعني
من يمكن ان يدفع مثل هذه الارقام هاد
جيتسين مسؤول استراتيجيات المناخ لدى
كلايمت اكشن ناتورك وهو الاتلاف العالمي
الرئيسي الذي يضم المنظمات الاساسيه اكثر
من 1800 منظمه غير حكوميه يقول يسال هذا
جيد جدا ادراج الخسائر والاضرار في جدول
الاعمال لكن هل سيكون الامر مجرد كلام او
نقاشا فعليا ومهما استشفيت من اجابتك
الاولى انه يعني غير المتفائل كثيرا ولكن
هل يمكن ان يكون هناك على الاقل التزام
نصفي همم يعني همم ان لم يكن كامله
انا شخصيا حضرت كثير من القمم يعني
العالميه للمناخ واعتقد بان الدول
المتقدمه عملت منذ اتفاقيه ريو في عام
1992 الى ازاحه يعني العبء المناخي وتدويل
القضيه من يعني رمت هذه الثقل عن عن كاهله
وعن اكتافها وزعت على العالم باجمع وهذا
ليس من باب الانصاف
في مؤتمر كوبنهاجن في عام 2019 تعهدت في
دفع ما يقارب 100 مليار سنويا لصندوق
المناخ الاخضر ولهذه اللحظه همم لم نجد
هذه الاموال والظروف المناخيه في حاله من
يعني تدخل الى المرحله الحرجه اذا نظرنا
الى الممارسات الدوليه السابقه نستنتج
باننا سنذهب الى نفس النتيجه همم كثير من
التعهدات كثير من
ولكن لا يوجد الالتزام على الارض
سمعنا الكثير من التحضيرات العالميه عن
انه سنشهد كوارث طبيعيه نتيجه الارتفاع
بالحراره والان يعني شفناها بالصيف الماضي
همم فعليا لماذا لا يكون هناك اجراءات
ملزمه وشفافيه بمن الدول التي لا تلتزم
باختصار لو سمحت
بكل تاكيد بان مجموعه الدول الصناعيه
العشره الاكثر يعني تسببا في زياده
الانبعاثات وهذا واضح في تقرير الاي بي سي
سي الهيئه الدوليه المعنيه في التغير
المناخي همم وضحت بشكل رئيسي من هي الدول
المسببه في زياده هذه الانبعاثات هذه
الدول التي تمتعت بثروات الارض وحققت رفاه
لشعوبها حان الان ان تدفع الفاتوره اليوم
قبل غدا اذا المشكله كالعاده ان الدول
التي تقرر هي الدول المتسببه بشكل اساسي
بتلوث المناخ وبالاحتباس الحراري شكرا
جزيلا لك عمر شوشان المتخصص في سياسات
المناخ من عمان تحياتي اليك شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الحبه الروسيه الاوكرانيه فقد
بيانو للمفوضيه الاوروبيه لان رئيسه
المفوضيه
بالدور السلبي الذي لعبته ايران بدعمها
لروسيا في عمليتها العسكريه البيان فان
الجانبين
العقوبات على روسيا التي تشن عمليه عسكريه
في اوكرانيا منذ اواخر فبراير شباط الماضي
تصل قيمتها الى مليار ونصف المليار يورو
شهريا لتغطيه احتياجات اوكرانيا للعام
المقبل
اذن ثمانيه اشهر مضت منذ قرر فلاديمير
بوتن شان الحرب على جارته الغربيه
اوكرانيا عداد الخسائر خسائر الطرفين
يسابق الزمن بل وتتجاوز تبعات الحرب
اطرافها ووسط هذه الحال تتعالى الاصوات
المناديه بالعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات
منها اوروبيه عالميه ومنها امريكيه السريه
اشهدت الحرب الجميله والدعم الغربي الا
محدود لاوكرانيا بدا يفقد بريقه فان
اقتصادات الغرب تحت ضغط التضخم وازمه
الطاقه صحيفه واشنطوس الامريكيه تحدثت عن
ان اداره
شجعت قاده اوكرانيا على التعبير عن
انفتاحهم للتفاوض مع روسيا والتخلي عن
رفدهم العلنيه للانخراط في محادثات
السلامه نتذكر انه في اواخر سبتمبر الماضي
بعد ضمه بوتن اربعه مناطق اوكرانيه لروسيا
اصدر زنسكي مرسوما يع ان انه من المستحيل
التفاوض مع الزعيم الروسي قال حينها
سنتفاوض مع الرئيس الجديد الصحيفه ذكرت ان
الطلبه الامريكي لا يهدف الى دفع اوكرانيا
الى طاوله المفاوضات انما هي محاوله
محسوبه لضمان ان تحافظ اكياف على دعم
الدول الغربيه نقلت واشنطن بوست عن مسؤول
امريكيه رفض الكشف عنه هويته ان السبب
الرئيسي وراء الطالب الامريكي من كياف هو
ان بعض شركاء الولايات المتحده ارهاقهم
الدعم الاوكراني الدبلوماسي المخضرم
الكسندر فيربو الذي شغل منصب سفير واشنطن
لدى موسكو ونائب الامين العام للنت وقال
انه اذا اصبحت الظروف اكثر ملائمه
للمفاوضات فلا يعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه
ستكون سلبيه لكنه اضاف انه في نهايه
المطاف الاوكرانيون هم من يقاتلون لذلك
على الولايات المتحده والغربه ان وحارصين
على عدم انتقادهم
لكن في الاسابيع الاخيره ازدادت حدت
الانتقادات الاوكرانيه للتنازلات المقترحه
بشكل كبير بل ووصل الامر الى حد وصفي من
ينادون بها بالحمقاء وبانهم يخدمون مصالح
الكرملين مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني بخيله
بدولاك قال يوم الجمعه اذا انتصرت روسيا ف
سنشهد فتره من الفوضى ازدهار للطغيان
والحروب والعباده الجماعيه والسباقات
النوويه اي تنازلات لبوتن اليوم ستكون
بمثابه صفقه مع الشيطان
ونتائجها مدمره
الاوكرانيون ويتسائلون عن سبب اختلاف اي
اتفاق سلام جديده عن سابقا يقولون ان
الطريقه الوحيده التي ستمنع بها روسيا من
العوده لمزيد من الهجمات هي هزيمه جيشها
في ساحه المعركه الرئيس الاوكرانيه
مؤخرا بان اول شيء سيفعله بعض انتصار
اوكرانيا في الحرب هو زياره شبه جزيره
القرم المحرره قال اريد حقا ان ارى البحر
لكن يبدو ان الغرب ووشن جادون بالدفع نحن
نحو المفاوضات التي ترى صحيفه وسط جورنال
انها قد تنتهي الى صفقه قبيحه لا تسمن ولا
تغني من جوعا مالك تويتر الجديد الماسك
الذي دعمك بالانترنت الفضائي
الديمقراوات الديمقراطيون التقديميون وبعض
اعضاء مجلس النواب الامريكي بداوا يحدون
اداره بيضا على الضغط على اوكرانيا نحو
المفوضات وبالحديث عن الوساطات والمفاوضات
نستذكر محاولات الرئيس الفرنسي
زار موسكو وتحدث مرات ومرات مع بوت هاتفيه
محاولا التوصل الى حل فشلت جهوده في كل
مره قبل ايام اكد ان مفاوضات السلام
يقررها الاوكرانيون لكنه عاده وط من باب
الفاتيكان التدخل والتحدث مع بوتن وعرابي
كنيسته الارثوذكسيه كيريل
[موسيقى]
اذا الجميع يدفع الان نحو المفاوضات لكن
التاريخ سيد الكريم بالالتزام بالمفاوضات
او بالاتفاقيات ليس جيدا كما ان
الاوكرانيين كلمتهم لها اهميه خاصه ان هم
يمتلكون افضليه على الارض بالفعل فلا يبدو
ان اي مفاوضات راويه قد ترى النور قبل ان
تنتهي معركه خيرسون التي لا تعني علامات
الانسحاب الروسي منها ان معركه كاف
لاستعادتها ستكون سهله فبينما تضغط قوه
الاوكرانيه باتجاه خرسان احد اكبر الجوائز
التي حصلت عليها روسيا بعد اطلاق حربها في
فبراير الماضي يريد الجيش الروسي ان لا
يستنزف قوته وان يتجنبا سحابا فوضيا اخر
كالذي حصل في تركيا
اشارات على ان القوات الروسيه تستعد
لمغادره المدينه اذ نقلت سكان والافراد
الى افضل بعيده لنهر النيو برو وتخلت عن
بعض النقاط التفتيش حول المدينه ومطارها
كان بوتين دعا الجمعه الى اجلاء المدنيين
من خيبسون في اشاره الى قرب اندلاع قتال
عنيف منتظر
[موسيقى]
تنقل صحيفه جورنال عن مسؤول غربي قوله ان
التخطيط الروسي للانسحاب كان متقدما وان
موسكو اعطت الاولويه على الارجح لتعزيز
مؤقت للقوات في المنطقه لتغطيه الانسحاب
مؤكدا ان معظم القاده الروس انسحبوا
بالفعل عبر نهر النيل برو وان روسيا تسعى
لتعزيز خط دفاع جديد على الضفه الشرقيه
لكن مسؤولين ومحللين اوكرانيين وغربيين
قالوا ان روسيا ستسعى لارهاق القوات
الاوكرانيه المتقدمه قدر الامكان قبل
الانسحاب اذا لازم الامر تقع وخيرسون على
الضفه الغربيه لنهر النيترو والاستراتيجي
مصدر الماء العذب الرئيس باتجاه شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وقد تم
عزل الخرسان الى حد كبير عن الضفه الشرقيه
للنهار بسبب ضربات الدقيقه الاوكرانيه ضد
قصور خطوط الامداد الروسيه الاخرى ايضا في
المدينه يتركز الهجوم الرئيس لاوكرانيا في
منطقه غيرسون على التوجه جنوبا نحو مدينه
نوفاكخوفكا حيث يعمل سد الرئيس على نهر
النيبرو اذا تمكنت اوكرانيا من الاستيلاء
على السد فانها ستؤمن السيطره على خط
امداد رئيسي لخيرسون وعلى طريق هروب محتمل
لكنه هناك عوامل عده تعقد تقدم اوكرانيا
الشتاء لم يجلب فقط الارض المتجمده ولكنه
سيعرض القوات لكشف المواقعها اكثر واكثر
مع تساقط اوراق شجر المستخدمه للتمويه
كما ان جغرافيا منطقه خيرسون تعتبر معقده
فعلى عكس خارج كيف في الشمال ودم باز في
الشرق فان معظم جنوب اوكرانيا مغطى
بالسهول حيث تترك الحقول المسطحه القوات
مرئيه للقوات الروسيه المتحصنه ما يزيد من
وتيره الاستنزاف ويبطئ من معدل التقدم
يقول قائد فصيل دبابات اوكراني من موقعه
على خط المواجهه جنوب شرق نيكولايف ان
الروس يمكنهم تشغيله طائره استطلاع صغيره
ورؤيه مدينه خرسون كامله عن بعد يقول ايضا
من المستحيل الاختباء
[موسيقى]
من باريس المحلل السياسي طارق وحده اهلا
بك معنا استاذ طارق مره جديده على شاشه
العربيه هل ترى
امكانيه فعلا لفتح هذه القوه قوه التفاوض
مهما كانت صغيره في جدار الحرب المستمره
وبناء على ماذا
مساء الخير استاذ طاهر وشكرا للاستضافه
سيدي العزيز من يتكلم عن طاوله مفاوضات او
طاوله حوار على هذه الطاوله ان يكون هناك
عرابيب منهم العرابين الرئيسيين انا لا
ارى الا البيت المتحده الامريكيه الان واا
ممكن قد تاتي الصين بمرحله يعني
لاحقه او حتى تركيا لان يجب ان نعرف جيدا
ان المحادثات التي بدات في تركيا لم تصل
الى ما نسميه همم نوعا ما للتوافق على حتى
مبادئ اولى بمفهوم التفاوض لذلك انا برايي
ما يطرح الان للاسف الشديد وانا اقوله هو
بصراحه تامه له علاقه بالانتخابات
الداخليه الامريكيه والتي هناك مزايده
قويه يلعب فيها الرئيس ترامب همم بدعمه
للجمهوريين وسمعنا اليوم ما قاله ان انه
سيذهب الى صديقه بوت ويتكلم مع صديق قطن
يعني هناك نوعا ما من المزايدات ولكن اذا
اخذنا بمفهوم المطلق انه هل امكانيه هناك
حدوث ما يسمى مفاوضات نعم الامم المتحده
جاهزه لهذا الموضوع الاتحاد الاوروبي جاهز
ولكن ما هي الخطوط او ما يطلب الطرفين
بهذا الموضوع هذا لا يزال غير واضح وخصوصا
ان الرئيس زيلانسكي رفع سقف هذه المفاوضات
صحيح بمفهوم السياده الى اعلى مستوى يعني
قوله انه يريد ان يرى البحر من جزيره
القرد هذا يعني انه يريد ان يسترجع ما صدق
عنه من عام 2014
تسلق مسار دينيا هي الان تحاول ان تضغط من
الناحيه الدينيه بين البطريرك الروسي كريم
من خلال البابا هل برايك يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك
على الرئيس الروسي بلاديمير بوتن
صحيح الرئيس مكروه عندما دعى الى هذا
المؤتمر مؤتمر السلام في في روما قال جمله
بالفرنسيه
دغولدومومونتو بالي بمعنى انه يعني وقت
شوي مزعج او او غير طبيعي لنتكلم عن
السلام ما يقصد فيه الرئيس مكروه انه لا
يوجد هذه الاستعداديه السياسيه ولكن
كالعاده هناك ما نسميه قنوات اخرى والقناه
التي يتكلم عنها القناه الدينيه او القناه
بين قوسين التي قد توحد الجميع بمعنى ان
الانسان هو الاهم وهذا الانسان بما انه
يعبد الله علينا ان نحترمه ونحترم ارادته
انا باعتقادي اين ذلك ايضا بخطاب البابا
في البحرين بانه يجب ان تحل مشكله هذه
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه وان نصل الى حل
ما ولكن انا باعتقادي يجب ان لا ننسى
جميعا ان هناك انفصال حتى في الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه ما بين الاوكرانيه وبين
الكنيسه الروسيه التي رفضت الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه ام تنضم تحت لواء الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه بل ذهبت الى الكنيسه
اليونانيه الموجوده في في اثينا وتحاولها
الى اقصى حد بمعنى انها تريد ان تنشئ ما
نسميه الحلف الارثوذكسي الاوروبي ضد هذا
الحلف الارثوذكسي همم يعني الاسياوي
الاسيا اوروبيا اوراسي الموجود في موسكو
انا باعتقالي الدعوه الى ما نسميه حوار
ديني مهم ولكن كالعاده اين سيصل يعني قد
يقوم البابا في زياره الى اوكرانيا وهناك
من يحبذ هذا الموضوع وبالتحديد السياسيين
الذين هم من اصول الكاثوليكيه اي شئ غرب
اوكرانيا بالتحديد في مدينه نيفيف ولكن
بنفس الوقت هناك من يقول ان الرئيس بوتين
غير متحمس ابدا بسمعه هذا الحديث لانه
يعتبر انه تاسيس لكل العمليه وليس له
علاقه بالمفهوم الانسان شكرا جزيلا همم
استاذ طارق وهبي المحلل سياسي من باريس
تحياتنا اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا
بانسلفانيا تجبر بيضا واوباما على زيارتها
ففيها كرسي قد يقلب موازين الكونجرس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وان انتقل مباشره الى
هذه الكلمه للعاهل المغربي الملك محمد
السادس في ذكرى السابعه والاربعين للمسيره
الخضراء
والاجتماعيه والبشريه للمنطقه
وفي هذا الاطار يندرج البرنامج الثانوي
الخاص بالاقاليم الجنوبيه 2015
[موسيقى]
شبيه العزيز
اذا انقل الامر للبرنامج تنموي مندمج
بغلاف مالي يتجاوز 77 مليار
الى اطلاق ديناميت الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه
حقيقيه
والمرافق الضروريه
وهو برنامج
الجنوبيه وتتحمل السلطات المحليه والمنتخب
مسؤوليه الاشراف على تنزيل مشاريعه
واليوم وبعد مرور حوالي سبع سنوات على
اطلاقه
فان تسمين النتائج الايجابيه
التي تم تحقيقها حيث بلغت نسبه الالتزام
حوالي 80% من مشروع الغلاف المالي المخصص
فقد تم انجاز طريق السريع تيزنيت الدخله
الاخيره
المنتخب الشبكه الكهربائيه الوطنيه اضافه
الى تقويه وتوسيع شبكات الاتصال
فما تم الانتهاء من انجاز محطات الطاقه
الاداريه
وعلى الصعيد الاقتصادي الذي يعد المحرك
الرئيسي للتنميه تم انجاز مجموعه من
المشاريع في مجال التجميل وتحويل منتوجات
الصيد البحري الذي يوفر الاف مناصب الشغل
لابناء المنطقه
الاشاره الفلاحين شباب من ابنائهم
وتالف معظم المشاريع المبرمجه في قطاعات
الفوسفات والماء
وقد شهيد المجال الاجتماعي والثقافي عده
انجازات في مجال في الصحه والتعليم
والتكوين ودعم المبادرات مبادره تشغيل
الذاتي والنهوض باللغه الثقافه الثانيه
باعتبارها
رئيسا للهويه الوطنيه الموحده
وفي هذا السياق المطبوع بروح المسؤوليه
الوطنيه
كمان ادعوا لفت افاق جديد امام الدين لم
يتنمويه التي تعرفها اقاليمنا الجنوبيه
الى السبب في القطاعات الواعده والاقتصاد
الازرق والطاقه المتجدده
شعبيه العزيز
لقد شكرت الصحراء المغربيه عبر التاريخ
سيري 69 انسانيه وروحيه وحضاريه واقتصاديه
من المغرب عمق الافريقي
هذا الدور التاريخ
العلاقات المتميزه التي تجمع المغرب بدون
قارتنا الافريقيه التي نحصل على تاسيسها
بما يخدم
مصالح المشتركه للشعوب من الشقيقه
وفي هذا الاطار
بادر نام اخينا فخامه السيد محمد بخاري
رئيس جمهوريه نيجيريا الفدراليه باتلاقي
مشروع انبوب الغاز نيجيريا المغرب
وياك ساده التوقيع التزام البلدان المانيا
للمساهمه
السياسيه لاهلها
واعتبارا لما نليه من اهميه خاصه
اشتراكه مع دول الغرب القاره فاننا نعتبر
انبوب الغاز لجي المغرب اكثر من مشروع
ثنائي بين بلدين شقيقين
وانما نريده مشروع استراتيجي لفائده منطقه
غرب افريقيا كلها التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
اكثر من 440 مليون نسبه
وذلك لمن يوفر لما يوفره من فرص وطمانات
في مجال الامن الطاقى والتنميه الاقتصاديه
والصناعيه والاجتماعيه بالنسبه للدول 15
المجموعه الاقتصاديه الدول الغربيه اضافه
الى موريتانيا والمغرب
انه مشروع من اجل السلام
والاندماج اقتصاد الافريقي والتنميه
المشتركه مشروع من اجل الحاضر والاجان
القادمه
كما نشيد بيدعم المؤسسات الماليه
الاقليميه والدوليه التي عبرت سن رغبتها
في المساهمه الفعليه في انجازه
العمل بشكل وثيقي ما شقاعي في نيجيريا وما
جميع الشركاء لكل شفافيه من اجل تنزيله في
اقرب الاذان
على جميع اشكال اشتراك المفيده من اجل
انجاز هذا المشروع الافريقي الكبير الكبير
خالد اذا طلب مواصله التعبئه واليقته من
اجل الدفاع عن وحده
الافريقي وهي مناسبه مناسبه للتراحم على
روحي
جلاله الملك الحسن الثاني اكرم الله مثواه
والارواح كل الشهداء
كمان وجه تحيه اجاده وتقدير للقوات للقوات
المسلحه الملكيه والامن الوطني والدرك
الملكي والاداره الترابيه والكويت
المساعده والوقايه المدنيه على تفانيهم
تحت قيادتنا في الدفاع عن وحده الوطن
وامنه واستقراره والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
تعالى وبركاته
[موسيقى]
على عده نقاد اقتصاديه وسياسيه واجتماعيه
تحدث عن مشروع الغاز مع نيجيريا وقال بانه
مهم للغايه في الرابطه الاقتصادي بين
افريقيا واوروبا وتحدث عن الصحراء
المغربيه واهميتها همم في المغرب والحصول
عليها استرجاعها الذي حصل عام 1975 عن
برنامج
سكان الاقليم الجنوبيه طبعا السادس من
نوفمبر 75 وما بعده يوم وطني في المغرب
يحتفلون به لاسترجاعهم الصحراء همم
الغربيه انا ذاكر التي كانت محتله من
اسبانيا همم يعني هو يوم يلقي فيه الملك
خطابا ككل عام وهذا ابرز ما ورد في متابع
في 360
الامريكيه نيويورك تايم تتحدث بان تويتر
يؤجل التغييرات بشان العلامات الزرقاء الى
ما بعد الانتخابات الامريكيه طبعا سيكون
عندنا ملف كامل عن التغيرات التي حصلت في
تويتر منذ استلام الان ماسك لاداره هذه
هذا
التطبيقيه كذلك ندخل في ملفها ففي
الولايات المتحده تتغير الانتخابات وتتغير
حظوظبان وتحافظ تنسلفانيا على اهميتها
كاحدى الولايات المرجحه
بالاضافه الى كل من الرئيسين السابقين
دونالد ترامب وبارك اوبا كلماتهم لحشد
الدعم قبيله انتخابات التجديد النصفي
ووفقه مراقبين فان بانسلفانيا تعتبر ولايه
محوريه في سباق السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ
بالتحديد فمقعدها قد يفض الاشتباك بين
الحزبين والذين لا يفصل في حاليا سوى
الصوت المرجح لكرس بيضا اعتبر خلال التجمع
للحزب الديمقراطي في الولايه ان انتخابات
التجديد النصفي ستكون لحظه فارقه في مصير
الديمقراطيه قائلا انه يجب ان يتحدث
في اشاره الى لون حزبه من اجل ضمان الفوز
على الديمقراطيين لوقف تدمير البلاد
وانقاذ الحلم الامريكي بحسب قوله
من الناخبين طلبه
وصفيه المرشحين الديموقراطيين خلال التجمع
انتخابي في مدينه بتروسبورغ الصناعيه في
ولايه ميسلفانيا
ملتهما اياهم بالسعي لتفكيك الضمان
الاجتماعي والرعايه الصحيه ومنح الشركات
الكبيره والاثرياء مزيدا من التخفيضات
الضريبيه
[موسيقى]
وصول رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
ميلوني للسلطه قد يكون نموذجا يحتذى به
لجناح في الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي في
الانتخابات النصفيه صحيفه واشنطن بوست
قالت ان ميلوني برزت كان نقطه مرجعيه
للجمهوريين المؤيدين لدونالد ترامب والذين
فسروا صعودها على انه تاكيد على قيمهم
وعلى اهدافهم يرى هذا الجناح في الحزب
الجمهوري ان جورج ميلوني تتحدث بوضوح عن
معتقداتها ولم تتنازل في وجه اليسار
وتغلبت على ما وصفوها جميعا بوسائل
الاعلام الفاسيه والعنصريه نتذكر انه فور
اعلان نتائج الانتخابات الايطاليه انتشر
على نطاق واسع
من خطاب لملوني تنتقد فيه ما قالت انه
هجوم مستمر على الاسره والدين تنفذه قوه
تسعى لعالم تختفي فيه اشكال الهويه على حد
قولها وحظي المقطع المصور حينها بتداول
واسع بين ابرز الشخصيات الجمهوريه
الامريكيه
[تصفيق]
كريستيانو
رونالدو
ونجاحها في حكم ايطاليا يمهد الطريق الى
السلطه لشخصيات اخرى كانت ذات يوم هامشيه
في اوروبا ميلوني من جانبها عملت لسنوات
من اجل بناء علاقات مع الحزب الجمهوري
الامريكي وتحدثت في فبراير الماضي في
مؤتمر للحزب في وقت لاحق وخلال مقابله مع
واشنطن بوست تجاهلت المرشحه جورج ميلوني
سؤالا حول ما اذا كانت تشعر بانها اكثر
انحيازا لجناح ترامب او الذين يعاردون
سطوته للجيولوجيه على الحزب اضافه الصحيفه
ان ميلوني اشتهرت في الولايات المتحده لان
خطابها في بعض النواحي يماثل الخطاب
دونالد ترامب باستنادها الى فكره الطبقه
الوسطى المنسيه التي تحتقرها النخبه بينما
تصور نفسها على انها مدافعه عن المستضعفين
لذلك افترض بعض الامريكيين من اليمين ان
فوزها يدل على تمرد شعبي مناهض للنظام
الحاكم او ما قد يطلق عليه الشعب في
مواجهه السلطه تبقى احدى اكبر نقاط نقاش
في الولايات المتحده تلك المتعلقه بجذور
حزب اخوه ايطاليا الذي تم انشائه قبل عقد
من الزمن وينحدر من مجموعه سابقه اسسها
متعاطفون مع موسوليني بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
في هذا الصدد اشار محللون لتجاهل الحكومه
الايطاليه مسيره لالاف الايطاليين مؤخرا
برموز فاشيه في بريدابيو مسقط راس
موسوليني احياء لمئويه دخول الزعيم الفاسي
للعاصمه روما
اذا كانت ميلوني كما ذكرنا وجها نسائيا
ايطاليه مؤثرا في الانتخابات الامريكيه
النصفيه لكن كيف ستصوت النساء الامريكيات
في انتخاب التجديد النصفي الحقيقه ان قوه
هذا الصوت ستكون حاسمه وقد تحدد نتيجه
الانتخابات بحسب تحليلا لمعهد بروكينغ
المعهد واشار الى ان الاصوات النسائيه
غالبا ما كانت من نصيب الحزب الديمقراطي
خلال السنوات الماضيه مرجحا ان تشكل
اصواتهن دعنا لجهود ديمقراطيين اعتمد
التحليل على اجراء محاكاه اظهرت زياده في
اقبال النساء ينعكس ايجابيا على المرشحين
الديمقراطيين
ارجع هذا التحليل زياده نسبه المشاركه الى
الجدل حول قوانين الاجهاض
اكد الامر ايضا استطلاع اجرته مجله
ايكونوميست ويوجوف اواخر اكتوبر
ظهر ان 60% من النساء من المشاركات في
الاستطلاع
سيصوتن بسبب قضيه الاجهاض نفسها كشف
الاستطلاع ان واحدا 51% من النساء
المشاركات اخترنا مرشحا ديمقراطيا في
الانتخابات النصفيه المقبله مقابله 46%
اخترنا مرشحا جمهوريه
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا الكنز الذي غفل عنه
الجميع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
لانه يتعامل مع توتير على انها شركه ناشئه
بينما بالحقيقه هي شركه ناضجه وفي سوق
تنافسيه
ابعد من هذا وتقول ان موقع التويتر اصبح
مهددا بالفعل بازمه وجوديه نتيجه الخسائر
الماديه الكبيره اليوم في كل الاحوال فان
ما يفعله ماسك في نظري الخبراء سلاح ذو
حدين يمكن ان يزيدما كاسب الشركه ويمكن ان
يقود الثقه فيها انجز ماسك في الماضي ما
اعتبره الكثيرون مستحيلا لكن تويتر يعد
نوعا مختلفا تماما من التحدي عما تعمل معه
من قبل وكالعاده مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائده
والمستفيد هنا هو شبكه اجتماعيه صغيره
تسمى ماستودون هذه الشبكه الموجوده منذ
عام 2016 والتي لم يسمع عنها الكثرون ربحت
منذ السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر
230,000 مستخدم وعلى عكس الشبكات
الاجتماعيه الكبيره فان ماستو دون مجاني
للاستخدام وخالي من الاعلانات تم تطويره
من قبل منظمه غير حيه مدعومه من التمويل
الجماعي ويقول منشئها يوجين ان المنصه هي
مشروع اكثر من كونها منتجا استهلاكيا ومن
الواضح ان اسماء ذات ثقل تركت التويتر
وانضمت لماستو دون مثل الممثله الكوميدينا
الكوميديه
[موسيقى]
الى الامام عبد الله درويش
حياكم الله مشاهدي الرياضي ضمن المعسكر
الاعدادي كاس العالم تغلب المنتخب السعودي
على نظير ستاندي وديا بهدفين دون مقابل في
العاصمه الاماراتيه ابو ظبي اليكم ابرز
واحداث المباراه
استاذ محمد بن زيد في العاصمه الاماراتيه
ابو ظبي المنتخب السعودي يلاقي نظيره
الايسلندي في مباراه الوديه تحضيرا
للنهائيات كاس العالم
منذ دقائق اللقاء الاولى مصوبا اكثر من
تسديده على المرمى الايسلندي
في الجهه الاخرى محاوله سهله تصل الى
الحارس محمد العويس
بعد مرور نحو النصف ساعه من المباراه نجح
سعود عبد الحميد في احراز هدف التقدم
للكتيبه الخضراء
[تصفيق]
والتدخلات العنيفه حضرت بكثره في اللقاء
الودي كانت هذه ابرز احداث شوط اللقاء
الاول في الحصه الثانيه اهدر المنتخب
رئيس الانديه تحضير شوف الحاله شوف الحاله
شوف بالحاله كيف يكون بالحاله في هذا
المنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
استقبال هدف التعادل
في المتبقي لم ينجح اصحاب القمصان الخضراء
في خطف هدفين ثاني لكن النتيجه تنتهي بفوز
السعوديه بهدف واحد هدى زين الدين العربيه
مبروك لمنتخبنا هالفوز
المنتخب السعودي للاصابه خلال المباراه
هيستندر وديه واتعرض الفرج الى اصابه في
الكتف عند الدقيقه الثانيه والاربعين من
عمر المباراه بعد ما سقط ارضنا اثناء
محاولته المرور بالكره من امام احد لاعبي
ولم تكشف في دائره المنتخب السعودي حتى
اللحظه نوع الاصابه التي وعنيا
المدربه مع استون فيلا الانجليزي حقق فوز
كبيرا على ضيفه مانشستر يونايتد بقيادته
بثلاثه اهداف في المقابله هدف في الدوري
الانجليزي الى المركز الثالث عشر على ملعب
بارك
باركيه اصحاب الارض بينما جاء هدف مانشستر
الوحيد عبر
الاقشاط نقطه بينما توقف رصيده يونايتد
عند 23 سنه
من جهته استعاده ارسنال صداره الدوري
الانجليزي من مانشستر سيتي بفوز خارج
الملعبه على جاره تشيلسي بهدف دون رد سجله
هو المدافع غابرين ورفع ارسنال رصيده الى
40 نقطه متقدمه بفارق نقطتين عن مانشستر
سيتي الثاني الحين بقيه تشيلسي سابع
سيغيبوا الفرنسي كريم بنزيما مهاجم ريال
مدريد مره جديده عن صفوف في فريقه ضد رايو
كان والاثنين في ختام المرحله الثالثه عشر
من مسابقه الدوري الاسباني
في المانيا اصبح يوسف موكوكو اصغر لاعب
يسجلوا 10 اهداف في الدوري بعد ما قال
دورتموند الفوز على ضيفه بخوم بثلاثه
اهداف في نظيف افتتح صاحب السبعه عشر عاما
يوسف من فوق وتسجيل الى اصحاب الارض في
الدقيقه الثانيه وضعف جيورين تقدم بروسيا
دورتموند في الدقيقه الثانيه عشر ليعود
بعدها مفكوك ويسجل هدفه الشخصيه الثاني
والثالث لفريق قبل نهايه الشوط الاول
بدوره تغلب بايرن ميونخ على مضيفه يرتب
الريم بثلاثه اهداف
التسجيل الضيوف في الدقيقه الثانيه عشر
واضاف يريك مكسيم شوربه هدفين خلال
الدقيقتين السابعه والثلاثين والثامنه
والثلاثين يتقدم بايرن ميونخ بثلاثه اهداف
بدون حقيقه
ضربه الجزاء
لاصحاب الارض
[تصفيق]
نهايه الموجز الرياضي عوده لاني لا راويه
وطه تفضلها
[موسيقى]
شكرا لعبد الله الى تصريح اليوم في
العربيه 360
جيدا كنزه توت عنخ امون ليس الا مقدمه
اكبر
المصريه
الذي وصل لاستنتاجاته بناءا على قراءاته
لاوراق مكتشف مقبره توت عنخ امون وبناء
على تحليله لبيانات
الملكه نفرتيتي اشهر ملكات مصر القديمه
تقع خلف جدار المقبره الحاليه فيا ترى ما
الذي تركته نفرتيتي اشهر واقوى ملكات
العالم القديمه
درب تلفح بالهموم منحنى يبكي
وطفل تلفح بالعلم خائف مما هواتن ورحل
الاخيره صارت شبه يوميا الجميع